[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
bonjourard merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous directeur adjint de la rédaction du
Figaro et Pascal Tournier est avec
bonjour Pascal rédactrice en chef
adjointe de l'hbdomadaire la vie on va
longuement évidemment parler dans ce
club de cette marche de ces marches
contre l'antisémitisme qui ont réuni
182000 personnes dans toute la France
dont plus de 100000 à Paris après le
surceau citoyens quelle réponse
politique alors que la présence du RN a
divisé et que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a a
pointé du doigt un échec on va revenir
sur tout ça et puis Alex on va reparler
de la loi immigration et oui la loi
immigration qui doit être votée demain
au Sénat puis ensuite elle ira à
l'Assemblée nationale et géralde daran
aura la lourde tâche de faire adopter ce
texte sans passer par le 493 on en parle
tout de suite dans le club mais d'abord
on commence par l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions et l'actualité dans nos régions
avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale c'est bien évidemment cette
marche ces March contre l'antisémitisme
182000 personnes ont défilé hier dans de
nombreuses villes de France dont
Bordeaux et Marseille où nous allons
nous rendre on va d'abord à Bordeaux
retrouver Jefferson des sport bonjour
Jefferson merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous
grand reporter politique à sud-ouest
Bordeaux euh j'ai personne pardon
comment s'est passé la marche du côté de
Bordeaux oui bonjour Orian oui ben le
Sud-Ouest vous le savez c'est'est
mobilisé également dimanche pour cette
grande marche contre l'antisémitisme et
pour la République alors ils étaient ils
ont beaucoup manifesté mais pas
seulement à Bordeaux où ils étaient 4000
ils étaient 2000 à La Rochelle 1000 à
peau 500 à mont-marçon 500 à Périgueux
200 AB Bayonne au total près de 10000
personnes ont manifesté dans notre
région alors beaucoup beaucoup d'élus
beaucoup d'anonymes aussi à Bordeaux
vous le voyez sur ces images le maire de
Bordeaux pierre urmi l'écologiste était
là le ministre du Budget thomas kaznav
était également dans le cortège avec ce
mot d'ordre et ce constat
l'antisémitisme n'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit tout ça s'est passé dans
une ambiance respectueuse et la plus
souvent silencieuse voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire et sud-ouest il
revient largement dans ces éditions
aujourd'hui Orian évidemment c'est à
lire dans les éditions de Sud-Ouest
merci beaucoup merci jeerson d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de ces
marches de cette marche du côté de
Bordeaux et dans tout le Sud-Ouest merci
Jefferson on ira à Marseille dans
quelques instants et puis on verra
comment s'est déroulé la marche du côté
de de Paris on a évidemment beaucoup
parlé de cette marche à Paris parce
qu'il y avait des personnalités parce
qu'il y avait des célébrités mais il
faut le souligner il y a eu des marches
dans toute la France oui c'était pas
uniquement un défil les parisien
effectivement mais heureusement parce
que d'abord il y a des gens qui peuvent
pass placé et puis je crois que c'est
bien justement que bien toutes les
villes toutes les régions s'associent à
ce type de manifestation qui n'est pas
uniquement parisienne et ce qui montre
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de monde
finalement puisque on parle de
185000 en tout sur tout le territoire
euh je pense que c'était une marche qui
était assez digne ce sont des marches
qui étaient très dignees qui ont pas du
tout été je dirais perturbé par des
des des slogans déplacés il y avait une
une grande dignité il faut noter quand
même aussi le succès puisqueon est
aujourd'hui dans les studios du Sénat et
de Public Sénat euh leè rencontré par
les présidents de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat à cette occasionl qui ont
lancé un appel donc un appel d'une
grande je
dirais dignité mais sobre à la fois euh
qui ont pris la parole à l'issue du
h et je trouve que tout ça avait
finalement beaucoup de beaucoup de
gueulle et on va en parler Pascal avant
de vous donner la parole on a vu comment
ça s'est passé du côté de Bordeaux on va
voir comment ça s'est passé du côté de
Marseille on retrouve Léo purgette
bonjour Léo merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous président et directeur éditorial du
Journal La Marseillaise il y avait
beaucoup de monde à Marseille 7500
personnes comment ça s'est
passé beaucoup de monde à marseillecoup
beaucoup de monde à exant Provence
également effectivement ça s'est passé
dans le calme dans la solennité aussi
parce que effectivement la situation de
l'explosion des actes
d'antisémitisme depuis maintenant un peu
plus d'un mois ben nécessite cette
réaction ce sursut citoyen et cette
solennité quelle que soit d'ailleurs les
opinions politiques puisque il y avait
côte à côte dans derrière la bande d'Ur
à la fois le maire de Marseille mais
également la présidente de la métropole
et du département et le président de
région qui ne partage pas tous les trois
les mêmes options le maire de Marseille
qui qui est à gauche et Martine vassal
et Renaud Muselier qui sont droite
macroniste effectivement il y a eu on a
parlé évidemment de de ces marches qui
se sont bien passées il y a quand même
eu un incident du côté de Marseille
c'est le sénateur reconquête Stéphane
Ravier qui a été
agressé oui il a été ulé il a été
malmené il n'était pas le bienvenu
d'ailleurs nous avions
publié ce weekend un dossier où un
certain nombre de
personnalités lié d'ailleurs à
l'histoire tragique de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale indiqué que l'extrême droite ne
pouvait pas être la bienvenue dans un
moment pareil et en effet un
arrièreptitfils de déporté lui a jeté de
de la cendre au visage en indiquant que
bah les Juifs ne voulaient pas de sa
présence merci Léo merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous le compte-rendu de
ces marches c'est évidemment à lire ce
matin dans la Marseillaise marche
citoyenne sur ce citoyen contre la haine
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
Léo purget d'avoir été avec nous avant
de voir comment ça s'est passé du côté
de Paris Pascal même question qu'ï
c'était important que ce sursut citoyen
ait lieu dans de nombreuses villes de
France bah oui parce que encore une fois
il faut pas que ça soit juste montré
comme un comme un rassemblement parisien
je pense c'était important aussi dans la
mesure où quand même tous ces différents
actes antisémites qui se sont produits
ces derniers jours ou semaines se sont
passés en dehors de Paris aussi donc
c'est important de montrer que le que le
pays dans son ensemble réagissait et que
surtout je pense ça qui est mon avis le
le signal le plus important quand même
après tout de de cette de cette marche
et que la que la communauté juive qui se
sentait quand même on l'a beaucoup dit
seul abandonné pas soutenu par donc là
on a quand même le sentiment qu'avec
cette marche il y a eu quand même de ce
point de vue-là c'est réussi et c'est
important effectivement que ça soit du
coup dans sur l'ensemble du territoire
et pas eu simplement un rassemblement de
de grands
politiques ce soit je pense quei l'autre
idée c'est c'est que finalement ça soit
pas simplement un rassemblement
politique mais aussi un rassemblement
citoyen je pense ça ça qui était aussi
très important à à mettre en enfin voilà
que que ça se passe pres de cette
manière làou il y a quand même quelque
chose de rassurant dans ce qu'on a vu
hier Yve dans ce soutien euh dont
parlait Pascal à à la communauté juive
et ces nombreux Français qui sont
descendus dans la rue même si évidemment
on peut déplorer qu'en 2023 on en soit
manifesté contre l'antisémitisme oui euh
bien sûr ce qui est intéressant c'est ce
qui est important c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a des des tragédies dans ce pays
euh et là il faut rappeler quand même
l'assassinat d'un d'un enseignant il y a
pas très longtemps des actes
effectivement antisémites euh qui sont
en forte augmentation il faut rappeler
qu'à chaque fois la la France se
retrouve unie puisque que il y a 8 ans
précisément et bien malheureusement il y
avait la tragédie du Bataclan et après
le le Bataclan il y avait eu aussi des
réactions charlieerdo pareil euh donc à
chaque fois la la la France se sa se
réunir ce qu'on peut déplorer euh mais
bon il faudrait aller dans le détail
c'est effectivement ce que disent
certains sur la la non présence ou
l'absence plutôt euh de représentants de
la communauté musulmane enfin des
musulmans des institutions musulmanes
euh ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
effectivement regretter mais dans
l'ensemble je dirais que euh il y a
quand même une grande solenité une
grande dignité qui a euh été à l'ordre
du jour ce ce dimanche pascal oui c'est
je voulais un peu rebondir là-dessus
c'est que je pense qu'en fait le mot
unité à mon avis est un petit peu trop
fort dans la mesure oùec vous venez de
de de de le dire et puis surtout d'un
point de vue politique là pour le coup
on a on l'a bien vu il y a quand même
des des grands absents il y a quand même
des différences aussi euh euh on le voit
surtout la France insoumise bien sûr le
grand absent Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais on
l'a aussi au sein du parti cétait très
divisé certains ont défilé à Strasbourg
clémentino voilà donc on va parler de ça
mais donc je trouve que c'est quand même
le mot unité est un petit peu
malheureusement fort et m et pu puis le
premier premier du duquel aussi bien sûr
le président de la République qui
n'était qui n'était pas là qui a voulu
garder du coup aussi une forme d'un
enfin se montrer comme le garant d'unité
nationale parce que justement tout le
monde n'a pas défilé tout le monde
nétait pas il a eu tort pour vous
Emmanuel Macron de ne pas participer à
cette marche à Paris en fait il faut
quand même pas oublier effectivement
vous l'avez souligné les représentants
du culte musulman n'était pas présent il
y a quand même je je pense
que je pense qu'il a voulu effectivement
se être le garant d'unité nationale et
de ceux aussi qui n'avaient pas envie de
de manifester je pense que c'était
c'était ça ça g dirais sa carte sa
partition donc est-ce qu'il a eu tort ou
pas l'avenir le dira mais lui essaie de
tenir les debout parce qu'encore une
fois quand vous regardarder aussi je
pense qu'on peut pas déconnecter cette
manifestation ce qui se passe aussi en
France de ce qui se passe aussi sur
l'ensemble du globe quand même vous avez
eu la
veille à Londres une manifestation qui a
qui a généré plus de 200000 participants
pour défendre pour défendre Gaza donc je
pense qu'il faut pas opposer l'un et
l'autre il faut au contraire moi je
pense que le mot d'ordre aura été de
faire lutte contre l'antisémitisme bien
sûr mais aussi peut-être lutte contre
tous les racismes qui aurait pu
permettre peut-être une plus grande
peut-être plus grande participation il a
fait une erreur Yve Emmanuel Macron
n'étant pas présent hier selon vous bah
on dira que son absence a été très
remarqué voilà effectivement j'entends
le fait qu'il ait voulu se passer
au-dessus des partis au-dessus des mots
d'ordre l'unité parce qu'effectivement
tout le monde n'a pas manifesté
néanmoins je pense que sa présence
aurait été un geste très fort euh elle
aurait été un geste très fort on se
souvient de mitteran en 1980 après
Carpentra qui était pas du tout
l'attentat d'ailleurs que on croyait au
début on se souvient de François Holland
après Charlie
Hebdo est-ce qu'il aurait dû manifester
moi je pense que oui il aurait pu
manifester et ça lui aurait permis aussi
peut-être parce que le message
présidentiel est extrêmement brouillé
pour moi j'entendais tout à l'heure
Robert
Menard il a raison Robert Menard c'est
ce que j'éc aussi dans l'éditorial de ce
matin c'est que vous pouvez pas faire du
en même temps là-dessus vous pouvez pas
à la fois dire
euh l'État d'Israël a le droit de se
l'État hébreu parce que c'est le terme
employé a le droit de se défendre et
puis d'un autre côté appeler un cesser
le feu c'est impossible c'est c'est
inimaginable enfin c'est c'est c'est
c'est complètement contradictoire donc
je pense que il gagnerait avoir une une
voix qui soit plus percutante plus
précise elle est devenue visible
aujourd'hui ça nature et oui je trouve
que il aurait dû probablement enfin il
devrait probablement être beaucoup plus
clair là-dessus il y a pas de il y a pas
de il y a pas d'ambigué à voir moi je
suis assez inquiet pour dire la vérité
sur ce qui s'est passé à Londres en
revanche euh d'abord ils était je crois
quelques 300000 d'une part et
deuxièmement il y a eu quand même des
appel à la haine qui était assez fort
proféré ici et là euh qui euh
je dirais dans une grande capitale
occidentale comme Londres moi m'ont
choqué un mot sur la ligne d'Emmanuel
Macron après on revient à la marche
Pascal elle est invible aujourd'hui je
trouve on peut pas faire du en même
temps là c'est pas possible en fait sur
sur une thématique de de cette
importance là qui est vraiment c'est pas
possible donc je suis d'accord avec vous
enfin c'est que c'est on peut pas
effectivement la veille dans une grande
interview donnée à la BBC dire qu'il
faut inesser le feu et le
lendemain c'est pas compati donc c'est
vrai qu'on voit bien que même depuis le
début du conflit il essaie de de jouer
sur les les les debouts donc c'est de
tenir les de bout pard en même temps et
je pense que c'est pas possible ça
marche pas donc il faut qu'effectivement
qu'il clarifie je pense sa position on
va revenir à cette marche et notamment à
Paris 105000 personne avec en tête du
cortège Gérard Larché briv qui était à
l'origine de cette marche et d'autres
personnalités politiques Unies derrière
une même band rô le RN lui était en
queue de cortège la France insoumise
était absente Jonathan
duprz pour République contre
l'antisémitisme derrière ce mot d'ordre
une foule calme et compacte Séta élancé
de l'Esplanade des Invalides hier
après-midi en tête de cortège ancien
président de la République ancien
Premier ministre mais surtout les
présidents de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat à l'initiative de cette marche
une marche civique dont l'ambition était
de dépasser les clivag politique dans la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme un objectif atteint
selon yel Bron Pivet Gérard larch
extrêmement réjouissant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui en France nous sommes
capables de nous rassembler aussi
rapidement pas simplement que ça soit
une marche faut qu'une marche conduise à
une démarche et cette démarche doit nous
conduire à plus que jamais les valeurs
de la République entouré des membres de
son gouvernement la première ministre
est venue défendre son action pour
protéger les Français de confession
juive policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats sont très mobilisés pour
passer aucun message de haine pour ne
laisser évidemment passer aucune
violence à l'égard d'un de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il est de religion
juive mais le cortège parisien de plus
de 100000 manifestants a connu quelques
tension en queue de cortège ce groupe de
militants Juifs de gauche tente de faire
barrage à l'extrême droite qui s'est
invité à la marche éic Zemour chef de
fil de reconquête mais surtout Marine Le
Pen entouré d'une vingtaine de
parlementaires rassemblement national
cette présence la chef de fil des
députés RN la juge légitime nous sommes
là où nous devons être Bale tel une
manière de couper cours à toute
polémique et de refouler le passé
antisémite de son parti soutien de
circonstances de Marine Le Pen l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe le
Front
National est un est un parti politique
que je combats et lorsqu'il s'agit de
dire quelle nation nous voulons être
lorsqu'il s'agit de dire que nous
voulons lutter contre l'antisémitisme
moi je prends tout le monde à gauche à
l'inverse certains préfèrent ne pas
banaliser la présence de l'extrême
droite oui aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national a une stratégie qui consiste à
instrumentaliser la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme à des fins racistes et
notre responsabilité c'est pas de les
laisser faire c'est pas de les laisser
occuper cet espace c'est au contraire
d'affirmer qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes là
aussi pour marcher contre eux contre t
ce qu'il porte le RN dans le cortège a
surtout motivé Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
boycotter le rendez-vouse droite et
l'extrême droite pourtant uni ont échoué
à reproduire les mobilisations générales
du passé le rejet de l'antisémitisme est
plus large en France ils l'ont rabougri
et rendu ambigu alors que le PS EELV et
les communistes ont défilé ensemble
l'absence du leader des insoumis accusé
d'ambivalence sur l'antisémitisme a été
vivement critiqué que monsieur bélenchon
ne participe pas à la manifestation de
cet après-midi parce qu'elle
rassemblement au National ça pour lui
c'est un prétexte c'est simplement que
lui a pris le parti du Hamas certains
élus LFI comme François Ruffin ou Alexis
corbierre ont préféré se dissocier de la
ligne Mélenchon en défilant dans le
cortège à Strasbourg
elle est dommageable cette absence de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ce tweet on va le
revoir toute la droite et l'extrême
droite pourtant uni ont échoué à
reproduire les mobilisations générales
du passé le rejet de l'antisémitisme est
plus large en France il on rabouger
rendu ambigu non mais il a fait un choix
depuis le début qui est un choix
électoraliste et clientéliste Mélenchon
Mélenchon fait du commerce électoral
euh donc ça passe par pour lui euh bah
ce qu'on a appelle la judéophobie euh
c'est vrai que l'antisémitisme a plus
tout à fait le même visage qu'il avait
par le passé et et ça passe par là parce
qu'il cherche le vote arabo
mususulman qu'il a réussi à capter en
partie il se dit qu'il y a encore
beaucoup d'abscensionnistes dans ce
camp-là donc il va continuer à les
chercher donc ça son son attitude est
absolument odieuse elle est quasiment
ignoble même on peut le dire
et voilà bon ben et et alors ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'on passe moins de
temps à condamner cette et à dénoncer
cette ce petit jeu là qui a parlé de
Madame Le Pen qui n'a jamais eu elle
pour le coup de propos ambigu qui n'a
rien à voir avec son père d'après moi
face à l'antisémitisme on on va revenir
sur les reine voilà c'est c'est on
devrait s' inquiéter de cette dérive de
anti alors sous sous prétexte
d'antisionisme qui quand même a des
relant d'antisémitisme de la part de de
de de la France insoumise vous êtes
d'accord Pascal il y a des relants
d'antisémitisme dans la
le je pense que c'est c'est d'abord
avant tout un calcul un calcul vous avez
raison pour moi c'est un calcul
politique avant tout moi je je crois pas
du tout à à une g des reland
antisémitisme chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
non moi ce que je voudrais souligner
plutôt c'est que à un moment donné je
pense que au sein de la France
insoumise de la part de François Ruffin
Clémentine tin qui était qui ont voilà
qui ont défilé à Strasbourg moi je pense
qu'il serait peut-être temps qui qui qu'
coupe qu'il fasse qui forme un un
mouvement enfin voilà qui coupe parce
que je suis pas sûr que ce soit
salutaire on l'a bien vu dans les
derniers sondages il y avait quand même
une même de la base de la France
insoumise ça ça commence à décrocher
enfin c'est ça commence je sais pas ça
commence mais en tout cas il y a ce
n'est pas approuvé cette attitude là
n'est pas n'est pas approuvé donc je
pense qu'il serait temps qu' qui est
s'il veulent vraiment avoir un avenir
qui coupe quoi sur le RN quand même un
mot évidemment y sur la présence du
rassemblement national hier qui a
suscité des polémiques des critiques des
interrogations pour vous elle n'avait
pas lieu d'être quand on a entendu genan
Bardella la semaine dernière dire je ne
crois pas que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite est-ce que le RN a vraiment
tourné cette page
al je pense que Jordan Bardella a fait
une maladresse terrible probablement
informé ou euh non ce qui est certain
c'est que Marine Le Pen n'a pas le
discours de son père et je crois pouvoir
dire qu'elle n'a jamais entretenu
l'ambiguïé et qu'elle n'a jamais voulu
assumer cet héritage là elle a voulu
rompre avec cet héritage là ce qui
n'empêche pas d'être sur d'autres fronts
dans la ligne droite de son père et du R
du Front national mais sur ce sujet-là
précisément elle a à mon avis coupé le
cordon ombilical ça ça me paraît très
clair que le rassemblement national est
hérité lui
d'individus ici ou là qui sont qui sont
restés dans la je dirais dans la ligne
de Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est fort probable
et d'ailleurs je pense que elle cherche
à s à s'en à s'en débarrasser de ces
éléments mais bon elle peut pas faire le
ménage du jour au lendemain donc je
crois pas qu'on puisse accuser non plus
Jordan mardella de quoi que ce soit de
ce point de vue mais mais bon il a c'est
sûr il a fait une faute un écart c'est
clair mais je
P Mar c'est très bien Marine Le Pen
c'est si il y a du calcul électoral
évidemment mais Marine Le Pen sait très
bien que si elle veut être présidente de
la République ce qu'elle souhaite
contrairement à son père qui lui était
là comme un trublillon dans le paysage
politique donc lui il agitait des
monstruosités comme exactement ce que
fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon aujourd'hui
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est s'inspire d'une
certaine façon de de l'attitude de
Jean-Marie Le Pen il y a 20 ou 25 ans ou
30 ans elle c'est très différente elle
veut rassembler parce que pour être
président de la République il faut
prendre il faut évidemment embrasser le
plus large possible oui alors moi je je
je trouve que c'est c'est là où c'est
moi pour moi c'est très problématique
cette présence du rassemblement national
mais il est vrai que là elle a fait
sauter un verrou symbolique énorme en
étant présente et en étant relativement
finalement accepté au sein du cortège
parce que certes il y a eu un peu quand
même des un peu de de remot et cetera
mais globalementelle était en que de
Cort voà mais globalement ça s'est quand
même plutôt bien passé et là elle a fait
sauter un verrou symbolique qui est
énorme et je pense qu'elle le sait très
bien c'est un calcul pour elle qu'elle
qu'elle a fait elle sait
qu'effectivement pour être président de
la République et là je pense qu'elle
veut vraiment être président de la
République il faut faire faire sauter ce
ferou qui est de d'associer cette
association de l'antisémitisme et de de
de son parti donc là pour les pour les
ses futurs électeurs c'est c'est
possible moi je trouve que c'est très
problématique parce que je pense que
au-delà de peut-être que elle à titre
individuel a rompu avec avec avec son
père mais il reste quand même des gens
autour il reste aussi des des des je
sais qu'elle a elle elle a cautionné
aussi certains événements en en Europe
où il y avait la présence aussi de
personnes antisémi moi moi je trouve que
c'est tout ça n'est encore pas aussi
clair et j'ajouterais quand même qu'il y
avait quand même er zour aussi qui était
dans le cortège excusez-moi mais quand
ERC Zemour réhabilite essaie de
réhabiliter le maréchal Pétin sur cette
sur sur cette question des des des Juifs
donc moi je trouve que c'est
problématique voilà je je le dis
sincèrement on va passer au second thème
de ce club on va parler du projet de loi
immigration Alex ce projet de loi
immigration il devrait être adopté hein
demain par les sénateurs mais dans une
version sénatoriale la droite et le
centre de ont durcit ce texte texte et
alors demain il y aura vote mais c'est
après que ça se complique politiquement
oui puisque après et bien le texte ira à
l'Assemblée nationale ce sera début
décembre et une partie des députés de la
majorité présidentielle compte déjà
effacer les durcissements qui ont été
votés par les sénateurs les républicains
et sans triste regardez ce que dit le
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale Sacha aier c'était
dans une interview la semaine dernière
au Figaro à l'Assemblée nous rétablirons
le texte ambitieux de l'exécutif tout le
texte de l'exécutif y compris le volet
sur les régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier dans les métiers tention
notre rôle est de faire voter ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale qui a le dernier
mot alors encore faut-il pour la
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale qui est relative je le
rappelle et bien encore faut-il trouver
des voies supplémentaires pour avoir une
majorité pour rétablir ce texte
immigration du gouvernement pour les
députés et les républicains il est hors
de question de voter un texte avec
l'article 3 initial sur la
régularisation de plein droit des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension ce projet de loi
immigration n'aura pas non plus les voix
du rassemblement national regardez ce
que dit Marine Le Pen hier dans le
Journal du Dimanche c'est une petite loi
inefficace et qui peut-être encore
nocive puisqu'elle permet de faciliter
les régularisation de clandestin
l'article 3 transformé en article 4 bis
par les sénateurs ne me va pas non plus
en l'état du texte qui sort du Sénat
nous ne le voterons pas alors si ce
texte n'a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien le gouvernement pourra
toujours utiliser le 493 pour le faire
passer en force mais dans ce cas les
députés les républicains menacent de
déposer pour la première fois de ce
quinquena une motion de censure contre
le gouvernement c'est c'est en tout cas
ce quiespère Bruno rotaillot le patron
des sénateurs les républicains qui
répondait une question de notre consur
Nathalie Moret sur France I le texte va
détricoté donc les apports très fermes
du Sénat serait abandonné et bien si ces
apports sont abandonnés j'attends de mes
amis à l'Assemblée nationale
effectivement qui dépose une motion de
censure et qui la vote à voir ensuite si
cette motion de censure a des chances
d'obtenir une majorité de voix car il
est peu probable que la gauche vote un
texte signé par les républicains sur
l'immigration merci Alex alors on se
disait que le plus dur pour géralde
hermanin c'était peut-être de convaincre
les républicains au Sénat là il y a un
texte qui va sortir du Sénat est-ce que
finalement le plus dur est encore à
venir écoutez oui parce que dans la
mesure où on l'a bien vu par rapport au
textte qui était voté au Sénat où
c'était quand même quelqu qu part à
droite toute quand même notamment avec
la la suppression de l'aide médicale
d'État d'État donc et transformé en aide
médicale d'urgence oui mais enfin c'est
quand même là encore une fois même si on
j'espère que l'Assemblée nationale va
rétablir cette ame mais enfin il y a
quand même encore une fois un verrou
symbolique qui a été qui a été qui a
sauté là c'estd que c'est possible de de
supprimer cette cette aide médicale
d'État donc oui là on a bien vu Gérard
amanin tout just avant le passage du
texte au Sénat à à toutes les
déclarations qu'il a pu faire pour qui
était pareil à droite toute pour
effectivement faire en sorte que la
droite et le centre vote le texte au
Sénat donc qu'est-ce qu'il va faire là
maintenant est-ce qu'il va faire au
contraire des des déclarations je dirais
très très pour pour pour que la la ça
soit plutôt plutôt voté à par la gauche
on verra mais oui c'est c'est je trouve
que c'est ça qui est tout très compliqué
c'est que finalement on passe d'un d'un
enfin qu'est-ce qui reste qu'est-ce qui
va rester du texte et surtout quelle
cohérence en fait finalement on va vooir
de ce texte notamment je pense à
l'article 3 qui mon avis va aussi
susciter beaucoup donc ce fameux article
3 qui est pour favoriser voilà voilà les
métiers en tention va aussi forcément
être l'objet de de pas mal de
cristallisation à mon avis dans le dans
le dans la dans les débats qui vont
suivre
il est coincé du coup Gérald haranin
entre la majorité sénatoriale qui a
durci le texte et son aile gauche qui ne
veut pas de ce durcissement oui mais
c'était prévu euh c'était tout le
problème d'ailleurs c'est là aussi où le
en même temps a bien du mal à se faire
entendre parce que finalement il arrive
à il arrive à satisfaire personne donc
le texte quiant qu'on a vu pardon il ça
a réactivé complètement le clivage
droite gauche au Sénat ce texte d'où la
difficulté du en même temps voà
exactement alors le le moi je trouve que
le le texte tel qu'il sort du du du du
Sénat finalement il est pas si éloigné
que cela du texte qui était proposé par
l'exécutif y compris pour l'article 3
euh parce que on peut y enfin le le le
on peut y trouver son compte si on
regarde bien dans le détail
euh après bon je pense qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale ça va être extrêmement chaud
ça va être bouillant pour dire la vérité
ça va être une foire d' poogne et je
vois pas comment le gouvernement va
pouvoir se se priver du de l'article 493
parce que je vois pas comment la la la
majorité présidentielle pourra trouver
une unité pourra se se montrer uni et je
vois pas comment dans ces conditions-là
ils pourront séduire
des voix venant alors il y a Liot le
fameux groupe charnière
lot qui est toujours sur lequel tout le
monde compte un pe monde oui voilà c'est
ça mais bon c'est très difficile de de
prédire ce qu'ils peuvent faire en tous
les cas pour les républicains ça me
paraît très compliqué qu'ils arrivent à
à avoir les
voix le le les voix nécessaires qui leur
faudrait de la part des républicain
ouais pour la majorité qui aura du mal à
avoir les voix des républicains et et
d'autant que Marine Le Pen on a entendu
Marine Le Pen pendant un certain temps
dire que elle pourrait voter ce texte
s'il était durci si l'article 3 était
supprimé là malgré la suppression de
l'article 3 pour le Sénat et dit hier
dans le Journal du Dimanche que le RN ne
votera pas ce texte oui alors après elle
est aussi dans son dans son rôle dans
son je dirais dans sa dans son rôle de
de de de enfin c'est pas de posture
enfin en tout cas de de voilà de de
marquer de crané sur une thématique
quand même qui est qui quand même son
fond de commerce depuis depuis toujours
hein donc donc donc c'est et puis donc
du coup une façon de mettre de mettre en
difficulté le le gouvernement donc je je
pense que c'est ass quelque part entre
guillemets c'est assez cohérent ENF je
pense par rapport à ce que ce que
représente son parti par rapport à par
rapport à ses idées et du coup est-ce
que la menace des républicains on a
encore entendu hier Bruno rotaillot dire
que si l'assemblée détricotait le texte
du Sénat il appelait ses amis àer à
déposer une motion de censure est-ce que
cette menace elle peut réellement peser
Sacha aier dans le Figaro y il disait
c'est une menace veine à partir du
moment où la gauche a dit qu'elle ne
voterait pas cette motion de censure
c'est une menace V oui c'est c'est la
grande c'est c'est la grande chance de
la majorité c'est la grande chance du
président de la République et de la
première ministre c'est que
effectivement euh ils ont du mal à se
mettre d'accord toutes les oppositions
parce que le gouvernement et l'exécutif
a aujourd'hui affaire non pas à une
opposition mais à des oppositions et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que depuis le
début de ce 2è de ce second mandat du
Président de la République bah ça se
passe pas si mal que ça la la la je
dirais que le climat est extrêmement
entendu
euh il y a parfois des
dérives dans le débat mais euh comme ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre et qu'ils ne
veulent pas mler leur voix les uns avec
les autres et bien le président de la
République enfin le le le gouvernement
l'exécutif arrive à passer entre les
gouttes on l'a très bien vu à l'occasion
de la réforme des retraites parce que
c'est pas passé loin quand même hein et
on va le voir
vraisemblablement avec cette loi
immigration et ça c'est une les chances
du du du du président de la République
et de la première ministre c'est d'avoir
une une chambre
morcelée comme on peut on pouvait en
trouver sous la 4e République oui al en
même temps je suis d'accord avec vous
enfin en même temps vous l'avez dit
vous-même il il va avir s
vraisemblablement qu'ils utilisent le
493 donc donc donc oui mais pour la
motion de censure oui bien sûr mais mais
c'est moi je trouve que c'est quand même
problématique maintenant à chaque fois à
chaque grand projet de loi un peu
structurant il faut utiliser le 493 donc
je trouve que d'un point de du
démocratique moi ça me pose un souci
donc je trouve qu'on peut pas continuer
à gouverner en permanence en utilisant
le 493 à ce moment-là quelle est quelle
est la je dirais le le le pouvoir la
réalité du pouvoir de des l'assemblée je
trouve ça problématique alors ils ont
passé quand même pas mal de textes he
même des textes important sur l'écologie
sur Oui mais vous voyez bien les grands
textes structurant aujourd'hui chaque
fois c'est 4 j'entends bien j'entends
bien mais c'est aussi le fait qu'en
France il y a pas la culture du
consensus bien sûr il y a toujours le le
dissensus est toujours plus fort et bon
bah c'est une tare je dirais c'est mais
ce sera un éche pour pour Gérald armanin
qui qui répète que lui il a toujours
réussi à faire passer ses textes en 493
oui mais d'accord mais là c'est le texte
majeur pour lui c'est c'est autre chose
donc c'est ser un échec politique ah bah
ça sera un échec personnel puisqu'il
arrête pas de dire que il pourrait
passer 1493 alors ne ne présumons pas
n'insultons pas l'avenir
mais on verra s'il arrive à se passer du
49 trois chapeaux et on verra ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée ce sera début
décembre et puis on verra si députés et
sénateurs réussissent à trouver un
compromis on suivra tout ça avant de se
quitter comme tous les jours on regarde
ce qui a la une de nos journaux
[Musique]
régionaux et Alex évidemment c'est la
marche contre l'antisémitisme qui fait
la une de nos quotidiens régionaux oui
18 182000 personnes ont marché hier dans
les villes de France pour dire non à
l'antim isme ensemble contre
l'antisémitisme titre le journal La
Dépêche le sursaut à la Une de Nice
Matin historique pour le dauphiner
libérer un grand nom à la une du
Télégramme ces marches ont donc eu lieu
dans plus de 70 villes du territoire à
Montpellier par exemple 2000 personnes
ont défilé pour exprimer le rejet
viscéral de l'antisémitisme et le
journal Midi Libre a donné la person
donné la parole à à certains citoyens
qui ont participé à cette marche Anne
par exemple précise qu'elle n'est pas de
confession juive qu'elle est est venu là
par solidarité et elle estime que ce
rassemblement peut aider à une prise de
conscience généralisée et selon elle il
faut que les personnes inquiètent
aujourd'hui pour leur sécurité
témoignent pour créer de l'empathie et
toucher le plus de monde an Nice 3000
personnes se sont rassemblées sur la
Promenade des Anglais et oui elles
étaient rassemblé hier matin devant le
monument du centenaire sur la Promenade
des Anglais à l'initiative du maire de
la ville Christian estrozi l'après-midi
c'est le maire de Cann et président de
l'association des mares de France David
Lisnard qui avait Luu à organiser un un
rassemblement républicain à Nice et dans
la bouche de beaucoup d'habitants qui
ont fait le déplacement c'est toujours
la même sidération je cite un un nois
qui se dit un qu est révolté un nous ne
sommes jamais assez nombreux pour lutter
contre l'antisémitisme il manquait au
moins 20000 personnes selon lui hier
dans ce rassemblement et d'ailleurs à
Lille où 4000 personnes ont marché et
bien le président de la communauté juive
de Lille Guben Soussan estimé qu'il n'y
avait pas assez je cite d'artistes
connus de chanteurs de footballeurs pour
rejoindre cette cause et la relayer sur
les réseaux sociaux où une quantité de
haine antijuive se déverse à Marseille
la journée a pris une dimension
historique et oui car hier dans la cité
faosséen c'était aussi comme chaque
année le jour de commémoration de la
rafle d'octobre 1943 au château de La
Verdière 40 avenu de la Rose 32 enfants
y avaient été rassemblés avant d'être
déportés le maire de Marseille était
présent lors de cette commémoration où
le souvenir hurlant de leur sacrifice
continue de raisonner une commémoration
qui a également raisonné avec avec la
hausse de l'antisémitisme actuel une
rescapé des camp et présidente de
l'amicale des déportés d'Auschwitz
Denise toros Marter 95 ans à dit ses mot
hier à Marseille il faut croire que
l'histoire bégay 80 ans après dans
d'autres circonstances nous revoyons
renaître l'antisémitisme merci Alex pour
cette revue de presse cette marche est
également de la Une du Figaro évidemment
Nive antisémitisme la France qui dit non
oui on a éidivement consacré énormément
de pages à cela et on suit euh cette
actualité de très très près depuis bah
malheureusement depuis l'assassinat du
du
professeuras et c'est allair évidemment
aujourd'hui dans le Figaro autre sujet à
la Une de La Vie Pascal oui c'est un
sujet sur no kids si je puis dire la
génération no kids c'est donc essaie de
comprendre cette tendance aujourd'hui pu
voilà une vie sans enfants exactement
merci merci Pascal merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et merci Yve
également d'avoir été avec nous merci
Alex merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain à 18h s public Thomas HUG et
nous on se retrouve demain on vous
souite une très bonne
journée